foreign
the public mind is not capable of
juggling as many objects at once as it
might need to deal with modernity and
one of the things that seems to have
slipped off the radar is the fact that
somehow this pandemic continues to ebb
and flow and are we have moved on to
Ukraine and inflation and all sorts of
other questions
as you point out you and I in our
Social Circle have seen an obvious wave
of covet now obviously one Social Circle
could be way off but the number of
people that we've had report
um covet in the last several weeks I
would say is alarming in light of how
rare it was a month and a half ago let's
say
um so anecdotally speaking there seems
to be a wave there also seems to be uh a
change in the way covid is behaving
several things are evident both from
anecdote and a certain amount of
exploration uh uh scientifically
speaking
so one thing that we are seeing is the
possibility that covet is moving lower
in the lungs and one thing that you have
seen you and I have seen in our
anecdotal
um uh pool is that little kids are
getting hit and they're not getting hit
with something very very minor they're
getting hit with something that is not
life-threatening but is definitely
debilitating for days yeah what is the
evidence that it's going lower and lower
in the lungs um Zach actually he's oh
he's getting me water getting ice well
okay
um it is referenced in an artist yeah it
is important hydration is important I
didn't end up with any water sounds oh
boy I see no worries um in any case
there is evidence that it's moving lower
in the lung of course all of these
things are difficult to ascertain
because of the noise in the data right
in other words we have different
variants as a question of which variants
get a name whether or not uh the you
know if you're seeing an anecdotal wave
of a particular variant and you're
seeing disease lower in the lung if the
two things are the same that requires an
awful lot of work of sequencing to
figure out whether a particular variant
is causing that right but that all
presumes that there's data at all like I
just haven't seen anything suggesting
lower in the lungs there is some
um what I will say is the reason I
wanted to call attention to this is that
the possibility that the disease is
moving lower in the lungs the apparent
pattern of it moving in the direction of
young healthy children has an ominous
ring to it because these are predictions
of Garrett vandenbosch and he has
predicted other things which we have yet
to see but should they unfold so let's
just be let's just be precise
um
Garrett predicted increased virulence in
the wake of uh Mass vaccinating with a
leaky vaccine during a pandemic and the
lower in the lungs is what you were
taking as evidence of masculence or did
he specifically suggest that we're going
to start to see it um infecting he has
specifically suggested that possibility
yes and more severe disease so both more
infectiousness and more virulence and
the lower in the lungs is a matter of
Greater vargulence
um
I don't know whether we're seeing uh
thank you an increased death toll
obviously or death toll per case
um
but
uh
the fact that we are seeing multiple
predictions from a model tells us
something about what we're supposed to
do right any model that successfully
predicts that which other models cannot
should be taken seriously right now it's
possible to get one or maybe even two
predictions right by luck right but the
more of these predictions that manifest
themselves
the greater the likelihood that the
model that generated those predictions
is overlaps reality in some important
way and I would also point out that
there is an added more subtle
um implication here which is because we
are at the beginning of the summer and
seeing these patterns
this virus which a was thought likely to
be seasonal I must say I doubted the
seasonality of it at first because of
its likely laboratory origin
but it is likely to be seasonal even if
the virus itself is not is indifferent
to season
our Behavior as human beings is not
indifferent to season our exposure to
vitamin D our likelihood to be found
outside these are all important facts
and so the effect that we are seeing a
major wave
while the weather is good here in the
northern uh hemisphere says one very
ominous thing which is that were the
weather bad and we corralled indoors and
not being exposed to vitamin D this
might be much much worse and therefore
the disease itself may be that much more
virulent and is partially being kept at
Bay by the the weather
what does that mean for what's coming in
the winter that's more complex because
we are seeing this wave and it is
possible that it will generate enough
natural immunity that by the time the
weather Corrals us and starts limiting
people's production of vitamin D A we
will gotten a substantial fraction of
the way to herd immunity at least to
these variants and so one does not want
to predict well winter is going to be
worse because if it's sufficiently
aggressive now at transmission that will
reduce transmission down the road and so
it's possible that it's summer
transmission although it means something
ominous about the underlying viral
Evolution uh is is a lucky break because
now is when you would prefer to have it
circulate so that people are better
prepared and less likely to transmit it
and when they do have lower lower viral
concentration
lower viral concentration when they get
it they will have gotten it with a lower
exposure and be less sick now yes
because because they tend to they're
more likely to be outside
um yeah all of yeah I know lost my train
of thought with regard to what I was
going to say in response to you
um
that all seems quite possible I don't
know what's going on in the southern
hemisphere yeah I don't either and part
of the problem with having a completely
unreliable news environment a
journalistic environment that doesn't
work is that it's the a we're not seeing
it properly reported in the Northern
Hemisphere and so nobody is inspired to
say well what is going on in the global
South and what does it imply and so you
know we're forced to you know to read
something closer to tea leaves you know
and to work from anecdote
um which is unfortunate it's not how
it's supposed to work yeah uh
I guess you know we don't have uh
certainty around what makes
some illnesses seasonal although the the
hypothesis that has been put forward
that seems to have the most support for
things like blue and cold uh are that it
is about uh you know the length of the
day is and the warmth of the days the
two the two obvious contributing factors
to health being uh the more likely you
are to be outside in the warmth uh
means that you will be generating more
vitamin D and also
um the the Melatonin that we talked
about
um many weeks ago and also that you were
just more likely to be outside in spaces
where it's going to be harder to get
infected because you're in as as you
just said
um smaller smaller volume spaces in the
winter larger volume spaces which is
usually the outside in the summer uh you
would
so you know this this may be wave this
is a very hard thing to talk about
because we don't have data we only have
anecdote and we it does seem like in the
last two weeks we're seeing this
increase and in one way you know if the
astronomical level were exactly at the
beginning of the summer because we now
call Summer
um between the summer solstice and the
and the fall equinox but that isn't
always how people have understood what
summer is of course you know like you
know Midsummer's Night Dream from
Shakespeare
um has mid-summer as the longest uh the
longest day of the year the shortest
night of the year which of course is the
solstice and that is also consistent
with while it is it will tend to be
warmer in July and August in many places
than May uh the days are longest in you
know June in the first half of July so
you know this you might expect Regional
differences to the degree that this
virus is in fact
has been seasonal and is moving ACS now
that here in the Pacific Northwest for
instance really our summer is just
getting started and it's once again very
cool and drippy here but boy our August
is perfect and really septembers are as
well whereas for many people in many
parts of at least the United States by
middle of May it feels like full summer
everything is growing everything is
verdant when we lived in Michigan
certainly that was the case you know the
universities ended by end of April
because historically you know the
growing season was such that you just
needed to be if this was your work you
need to be on the farm uh for you know
beginning you know really before April
uh but certainly for you know full time
May June July August and uh and the the
substantial differences in heat profile
and seasonality and what's growing when
and in therefore when people are most
likely to be outside should be expected
to affect therefore when the seasonal
viruses and whether or not this one
still is is the question uh will be most
rampant several points one there are two
factors in seasonality potentially one
is the virus evolving to take advantage
of opportunities right so there can be
things
um inscribed in the Genome of a virus
that might predispose it to
um play games that work better in one
season or another so for instance is to
work better at a particular temperature
uh yeah be more effective like be more
transmissible outside a body at a
particular temperature yeah perhaps more
tolerant of existing on a Surface
um and that you might not be likely to
encounter Outdoors anyway there are lots
of ways it could evolve that would
provide a bias and then there are ways
in which a virus that was completely
indifferent to the information about
what season it was would still appear to
behave seasonally because of our shift
in Behavior which is radical
[Music]
oh